i'm going to take you live to dublin now
where shin fein now the largest party in
the northern ireland assembly for the
first time is holding a press conference
we have their assembled mary lou
mcdonald michelle o'neill let's have a
listen now need to be up and running the
executive and the assembly it is a
matter of disgrace that the dup it has
to be said with the support and
connivance of the british government
have moved to frustrate the democratic
will of the people there has to be a
respect for the democratic outcome of
that election there has to be a respect
for people's votes
and it has to be recognized that there
is very very serious work to be done i
mean we are in the grip of a cost of
living crisis people are literally
struggling to meet their grocery bills
to keep their their homes uh heat and uh
lit
and we are clear that we need and we are
insistent that there is a functioning
government in the north that we don't
simply have a caretaker ministers in in
key positions but we actually have
people who can act and take decisions
now to put money into people's pockets
to make the necessary investment in our
health services
and you know
boris johnson can't play games with the
people of the north or with the island
of ireland
he has connived with the dup
to use ireland to use the north of
ireland to use
unionism in ireland as a pawn in a wider
game that is being played out
with the european union and that is
clearly a shameful tactic and approach
and it's one that is absolutely not
acceptable
we'll meet boris johnson on monday
in the north
and i know that uh michelle as as first
minister i i hope uh we hope will meet
with the taoiseach in in the course of
the coming week also michelle do you
want to add anything or connor we will
go to questions
what exactly are you going to do next
about this then obviously you described
as disgraceful as a situation around
this dormant assembly
is it time then for perhaps you know the
irish government for the us government
for the eu to step in and put additional
pressure then on the british government
to make sure that things can move on
well look it's it's time for all hands
on deck michelle led our team yesterday
into the assembly we committed in the
course of the campaign that on day one
that shin fein would turn up ready for
work ready to do the business and we
have been as good as our word and what
we simply want is for the outcome the
natural outworking of the election to
take shape the establishment of an
executive the nomination of first
minister of deputy first minister the
nomination and appointment of a speaker
i mean the dup have not simply uh called
a hold to the formation of an executive
they have equally
attempted to place a vita on the
operation of the assembly i mean it's it
is outrageous
um and the british government have
assisted the dup
in these blocking tactics and they need
to desist and certainly when we meet
boris johnson on monday we will be
making that very clear to him i think
the response internationally to these uh
tactics shameful tactics by the dep has
been um
to call them out and to say very clearly
that it is not just the will of the
people in the north to have progress and
an inclusive executive and a first
minister for all but that is the demand
of ireland in its totality and indeed
our international partners
meet boris johnson on one day that you
could actually be facing disaster you
could be facing the prime minister who
is going to announce that
unilaterally legislation
look we've been here before paul um as
you know is the the british government
throughout the the process of of brexit
and the negotiation and lester b said
the ratification of of the protocol have
not acted in good faith they have
consistently um threatened to act and
have acted unilaterally and let's just
be clear the protocol is going nowhere
the protocol is a necessary outworking
of brexit for which uh the the tory
party and the dup campaigns
um
and uh
the british government cannot use
ireland uh as a pawn we won't be the
collateral damage in in the the brexit
negotiations our priority is to get the
institutions up and running i don't
think that anybody should be brought
back or spooked
by um more actions or rhetoric of bad
faith from the british government i
think we're all well acquainted with
that uh now and what the british
government embarrassed johnson needs to
understand is that they may wish to
try and thwart or delay or stall change
and progressivity
in ireland they will not succeed i think
it was very clear during the election
campaign
michelle what people wanted what the
message was loud and clear from people
and it was for partnership for
constructive politics
and above all else in the here and now a
response
to the really really difficult
circumstances in which people find
themselves so yes we have heard the
message from london
they are saber rattling they're engaging
in a game of brinkmanship we have been
here before we have said before and we
reiterate uh again that the people of
this island deserve so much better than
that and boris johnson and his
government cannot play these dangerous
games uh with ireland
and we will continue to demand that the
the outcome of the election is
acknowledged and respected
do you believe you'll actually get a
crack at the office of first minister
before the end of the summer but it does
here at all i mean what's your elephant
heading sir
there should be no delay we were there
yesterday we turned up as we promised
the electorate throughout the campaign
itself that we would turn up on day one
that we'd work to put money in in their
pockets because people are struggling
with the cost of living crisis people
are our health services on its knees and
needs fixed so we're there to do
business we want to work in partnership
with others but the dup failed to turn
up the field on day one to actually form
an executive let us get back to work do
what we need to do for the public the
public voted in strong strong numbers
probably the largest election turnout
that we've seen in a long time but they
voted for politics to work they voted
for parties to work together but the dup
have done two things they're punishing
the public for their own brexit mess
they're being facilitated in that by the
tories so when boris johnson comes here
comes to belfast on monday we will meet
with them but we put it very strongly to
them they are punished in the public and
that is not acceptable and boris johnson
has no mandate here on the island of
ireland but yet not he's facilitating
this dup madness at a time whenever the
people that need us to be there for them
so um i want the opportunity to lead i
want the opportunity to be in the office
of first minister i think it's about the
future it demonstrates the real change
that actually is happening in our
society but people need politics to work
and i'm going to continue to work at
that every day because that's what the
election said
the response from the dep is that there
is
a mandate to stay out
they have received that mandate and on
that basis then that country will turn
them to the issues with both what have
been resolved
i think the are being dishonest with the
public they fought this election on a
five-point plan and they've failed to
turn up on day one they are blocking
progress they're blocking an executive
be informed they're blocking a
government that can actually put money
in people's pockets they're blocking us
starting to fix the health service the
rest of the parties were there yesterday
to do business together so when the dup
talk about consensus they actually mean
consensus on their terms they actually
mean they do use pa p's way or no way
that's not acceptable we didn't consent
to brexit but it's been fostered upon us
the protocol is here to stay so there
needs to be an insertion of honesty into
the conversation the protocol is here to
stay are there ways to smooth its
implementation yes and we're up for that
but that should not block the
establishment of an executive
if it is the case we head into the
unilateral territory which has been
threatened for so long for making plans
it does bring back the possibility of a
hardcore it does bring back that as a
real thing you meant to use the words
and dangerous brickmanship game that's
being played
can you quantify what the level of
danger you think it is because suddenly
you just always get very real again
people might have thought it would have
gone away
no i mean it is very dangerous it's
reckless it's it's a game of
brinkmanship very cynically carried out
by a tory government in london that has
no care for the island of ireland north
or south
where we need to be very much focused is
on protecting irish interests north and
south east and west that's our job to
protect the interests of everybody who
calls this island home and our clear
interest is to ensure that the protocol
is implemented in a way that is smooth
in a way that ensures that business can
work in in a way that ensures that we
that that everybody benefits um so i
would just caution against anybody being
overly spooked or distracted by the kind
of the loud rhetoric from boris johnson
we need to keep our eye here on the
prize and the prize is to establish
functioning institutions good government
but also to ensure that the the outcome
of brexit does not negatively harm the
island of ireland that's where our focus
is we meet boris johnson on monday
we'll set out the stall very very
clearly uh to him we're not one bit
naive as to what's happening here it is
very clear that the tory government in
london is in cahoots with the dup to
stall
and to hold back progress
to frustrate the will of the people as
expressed in the election and that to
anybody who calls themselves a democrat
is clearly unacceptable and clearly
shameful and that case will be made to
boris johnson and i have no doubt that
the government in dublin that our
partners at a european level and indeed
across the atlantic in the united states
of america will reiterate that message
loud and clear
national maternity hospital earlier on
this morning and the further and higher
education minister simon harris
indicated that it was likely there could
be some form of codicil memorandum
addendum stuck into any deal which would
try and clarify those two difficult
words
which we've heard about would that be
something you'd welcome i i think um
clarity on on that question is
undoubtedly very welcome i think people
want to know that all
lawful services will be provided to to
women um in the new maternity hospital
and that the
the will of the woman is is uh respected
fully so i think that is welcome
obviously we await uh
seeing what what the the wording or the
the content of this catalog
addendum might be um but there is still
the outstanding issue of ownership you
know that that is still a very very
vexed question and the need for a public
hospital which will
um cost very considerable amounts of
public monies being cited on public land
and that question unfortunately the the
government have proved unwilling to even
entertain what i think is a very
reasonable suggestion and that is that
the t shook the tarnish then the
minister for health sit down with the
saint vincent healthcare group
speak to them and
press for a solution which is a clean
transfer of the site of the land
to the state after all that was what was
in
initially envisaged so i i would urge
not just a resolution of one issue but
resolution of the second issue which is
the question of ownership of the site
we're going to leave that conference
there mary lou mcdonald michelle o'neill
from